If there remained any lingering optimism that
the world is too interconnected for large,
Capitalist nations to go to war, February
24th, 2022 was the final nail in the coffin.
The Russian invasion of Ukraine is far
from the first armed conflict this century.
Nor is it even the first initiated by Russia.
But in its scale and proximity
to the European continent,
it’s perhaps the most symbolically significant.
Clearly, the Golden Arches Theory of history
— which suggests no two countries home to
a McDonald’s franchise will
fight one another — fails to
capture the senseless violence some
leaders are capable of inflicting.
But although we aren’t living in the
“End of History”, neither could any
simple economic model predict the scale or
speed of the corporate exodus from Russia.
The same companies which lend only lip
service to climate change — many of which
had not millions but billions invested in
the country — simply packed up and left,
and all in the span of a few weeks.
When McDonald’s announced its complete exit from
the Russian market 81 days after the war began,
we learned another important lesson…
Not only is globalization not inevitable,
but it can all unravel in an instant.
And you can bet that if these largely
self-imposed corporate sanctions surprised
us, they absolutely shocked China,
where everything is pure business.
Everyone, everywhere is now quietly wondering:
If Russia, the world’s 11th largest economy,
could be effectively isolated overnight,
could the same thing happen to China?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula, where
you can watch the now-released 3rd episode of
my Original Series. This one is about China’s
dominance of rare earth elements — the essential
ingredients for everything from smartphones to
guided missiles. We talk about how China came
to monopolize their production and whether
or not the U.S. should be worried. With the
$15/year CuriosityStream and Nebula bundle,
you get access to the entire exclusive series,
which is now an hour long, and covers
how Chinese censorship actually works,
along with why it won’t abandon COVID-Zero
anytime soon. If you enjoy these videos,
sign up now to essentially get 50% more of them.
China is not Russia.
Placing the latter’s 1.4 trillion dollar GDP
next to China’s helps put things in perspective.
The Russian economy is ten times
smaller. You could merge it, in fact,
with the Korean, Brazilian, Australian,
Spanish, Mexican, Canadian, Italian,
and French economies and
it would still be smaller.
Perhaps more importantly, Russia is insulated.
Its largest export market is China, which buys
13% of its goods. And of its top 8 buyers,
half could be characterized as if not
an ally, at least somewhat friendly.
Just about 5% of its imports
came from the United States.
Over one fifth from China and
in third place is Belarus.
Now, compare that with China’s
top export destinations.
The first thing you’ll notice is that a whole
one-sixth goes to just one country: the U.S.
And, in reality, that number is likely much
larger because second place is Hong Kong,
where many Chinese goods are re-exported abroad.
Immediately below Hong Kong are
non-NATO American allies Japan
and South Korea. And slightly lower, NATO
allies Germany, the Netherlands, and the U.K.
China, in other words, is much more
dependent on America and her allies.
But trade, in aggregate, is a very crude proxy
for how much two countries depend on one another.
For one, what is being traded matters a lot.
To spell out the obvious: the current
flow of goods is driven almost entirely by
cost. And costs are based on the current
circumstances. If those circumstances changed,
most trade wouldn’t disappear, it would
simply be re-organized and re-routed.
Take Australia, for example.
The country produces a large quantity of iron,
coal, and beef — of which China
is, by far, its largest customer.
In 2000, just 5% of Australian exports went to
China. By 2020, that number had increased sixfold.
So dependent on its Northern neighbor is Australia
that it has often been described — only partly
humorously — as a Chinese satellite state.
Clearly believing this narrative, China
tried to bully what it perceived as small,
easy prey in 2020 over what
it called “14 grievances”,
which include Australia’s call for an
investigation into the origins of COVID-19.
What followed was nothing short of a
full-blown trade war. China imposed
tariffs, duties, and bans — not to mention a
state-organized boycott — of Australian imports.
But Beijing overplayed its hand.
While the trade disruption wasn’t without costs,
Australia turned around and found new buyers.
First, China began looking
for new sellers to replace
Australia. Those turned out
to be Russia and Indonesia.
Russia and Indonesia previously supplied
India, Japan, and South Korea, who were,
likewise, now in need of a new supplier. As you
can see here, their new supplier was Australia.
Think of trade like a city’s road network.
Sure, you can block off one street,
but traffic will simply find a new route. Any
disruption will ripple throughout the city,
causing some congestion, but a new
equilibrium will eventually be found.
Bans, tariffs, trade wars,
and sanctions, therefore,
aren’t necessarily as catastrophic as they may
seem. It all depends on what is being traded.
Australia was selling iron, coal,
and beef — high-demand commodities for
which there are many possible buyers.
Likewise, although oil, iron, soybeans,
and copper are among China’s largest
imports by value, we can safely assume
it will always have access to a seller.
And not just because these are commodities.
In the wake of U.S. sanctions against
Russia, many were surprised by the
degree of international cooperation.
Even historically neutral countries
like Switzerland and Singapore proactively
complied and publicly denounced the war.
If China were to, say, seize and
occupy an outlying Taiwanese island,
it would prompt similar reflection
from fence-sitters like Singapore.
But getting everyone to cooperate with
the toughest kind of sanctions against
China would be a much more difficult challenge.
Iron, soybeans, and oil would likely
keep flowing from Brazil, for example.
The country simply has too much to lose.
If push came to shove, China could even roll
back some of its environmental regulations,
allowing it to more easily source dirty
commodities like coal domestically.
The catch? Everything would be more
expensive. A lot more expensive.
No country has benefited more from the U.S. Navy’s
guarding of the world’s shipping lanes than China.
If it were ever to withdraw that protection,
China would enter a world of hurt.
…But that’s the easy stuff. The real
challenge would be advanced technology.
You don’t have to take my word for it, either.
China has assembled what is effectively a list of
its own weaknesses — technologies and components
it wants to be able to produce domestically.
Despite investing many tens of billions of
dollars into commercial airplane manufacturing,
for example, China is almost entirely
dependent on foreign imports.
Its most commercially viable
domestic plane, the C919,
still requires parts from GE, an American company.
Tellingly, no one outside of China buys it.
If the U.S. ever applied maximum sanctions,
Chinese commercial aviation would simply
crash and burn, though its vast network of
high-speed rail would somewhat soften the blow.
At the very least, the industry would be
forced to regress something like 40 years.
But even this hypothetical bloodbath
pales in comparison to semiconductors.
There’s a reason they receive so much airtime
in discussions about China: the country buys
a ton of them. In purely dollar terms, it
imports as many semiconductors as it does
crude oil. And that’s saying a lot — China buys
one-fourth of the entire world’s oil, by value.
Even after investing $22 billion on
a national semiconductor fund in 2014
and plenty more since, the truth is that China
remains years behind. What it produces are almost
exclusively low-to-medium-end chips.
If cut off from imports, it’d still
be able to make things like microwaves
and televisions, but not iPhone 13s.
It’s not that China is behind and catching up.
In terms of trade, it’s behind and
actively losing ground. Here you can
see its semiconductor deficit not shrinking,
but growing over time — and quite dramatically.
9 Women can’t make a baby in a month, and money
alone can’t instantly manifest an
advanced semiconductor industry.
Because China has been deliberately
blocked from access to crucial ingredients
like the Dutch lithography machines
required to make the smallest chips,
the only path forward entails billions of dollars
of investment, and many years of patience.
According to one estimate, the country
has a shortage of 300,000 semiconductor
engineers. At the current rate of 30,000
new workers entering the industry each year,
it would take at least ten years to catch up to
2022 technology. And that’s being optimistic.
Now, in fairness, some number of semiconductors
and other essential parts could “fall off a
truck”, so to speak, and find their
way to China, even with sanctions.
Researchers, for instance, recently
disassembled Russian weapons used
in Ukraine only to discover American and
European chips, engines, and other parts.
Shell companies and intermediaries can covertly
buy sanctioned parts. And given the state of
consumer electronics today, enemy militaries can
even source parts from products sold at Walmart.
But the fact remains: China is
deeply dependent on Western imports.
Just look at the growing divide between
what it says and what it actually does.
Xi Jinping’s first overseas
trip as President was to Moscow.
And on February 4th this year — just 20
days before the invasion of Ukraine — Putin
was Xi’s first in-person meeting with
another head of state in over two years.
Since then, China has refused to condemn the
invasion, or even refer to it as an invasion.
Officially, it, quote, “does not
participate in” sanctions against Russia.
But the reality is, although it may do
so very quietly, it does participate. No
Chinese bank — no matter how patriotic — is
willing to risk defying American sanctions.
Likewise, in 2021, China passed an
“Anti-Sanctions law”, which essentially
makes it illegal for Chinese nationals to
comply with American sanctions against China.
Make no mistake: this law is driven
not by supreme confidence but rather,
deep-seated fear. If sanctions were nothing
to worry about, it wouldn’t be necessary. Its
purpose is to increase the cost of sanctions,
thereby, in theory, making them less likely.
But this reluctance goes both ways.
That divide between saying and doing
is also quite large in America.
Trade is, of course, a two-way street.
Chinese imports mean dollars in the bank for
American companies. Not to mention that many
Chinese “imports” are then assembled into
final products and shipped to the States.
This is a list of companies on the S&P with
the highest percentage of sales in China.
With the sole exception of Wynn Resorts,
which operates casinos in Macau, 9 of the
top 10 are suppliers of semiconductors
or other advanced technology components.
Not far behind, with one-fourth
of its revenue coming from China,
is the second-largest public company
on earth by market cap: Apple.
If the American semiconductor industry
were cut off completely from China,
it would lose at least $80 billion and 125,000
jobs, according to the Commerce Department.
Beyond lost sales, these companies rely on China
to reach their economies of scale. If they lost
half their unit sales, you can expect they’d
be less than half as competitive, therefore,
globally. Such an extreme move would mean the end
of U.S. dominance over the highest of high tech.
Taken as a whole, American companies have
around $400 billion at risk in China.
“Decoupling”, as it’s often called, would
lower American GDP by an estimated 2%.
Chinese companies, by comparison,
only generate about a third as much
revenue within the United States.
The U.S.-China relationship
is really unlike any other.
Inevitably, each will move
toward greater independence.
Already, some American companies are
diversifying their supply chains. Huawei, ZTE,
and officials in Hong Kong have,
likewise, already been sanctioned.
…But, however much leaders in
each country may deny this fact:
“Decoupling” will be a slow and difficult
process, and almost certainly, never be complete.
The most extreme form of sanctions
would require a total trade blockade,
which is itself an act of war.
To seize China’s foreign exchange, like the U.S.
did to Russia, would be no less unthinkable.
Indeed, even Russia is granted exceptions — to
export fertilizer to the world and oil to Europe.
There is, however, one “trump
card” we haven’t discussed.
China controls ac cess to the vast majority
of what are called rare earth elements — the
ingredients required to produce almost any piece
of modern technology — from smartphones to F-35s.
In 1992, Deng Xiaoping proclaimed, quote, “The
Middle East has oil; China has rare earths”.
That’s the subject of the new,
17-minute, 3rd episode of our new Nebula
Original series — “China, Actually”.
Sign up now and you’ll also get
access to the first two episodes.
The first is about how Chinese censorship actually
works and why there are protests in China.
The second is about the real reason China
refuses to allow even a single case of
coronavirus and why it likely won’t
fully open its borders anytime soon.
Altogether, that’s an hour of exclusive PolyMatter
content. You’ll also get access to future videos
in the series. Plus you get ad-free and
early access to all PolyMatter videos.
And other Original series on Nebula, not
to mention access to CuriosityStream,
home to great full-length documentaries
on science, technology, and history.
After I finish recording this video, for example,
I’m going to watch this one
about how container ships work.
Get all that for just $15/year right
now with the Nebula and CuriosityStream
bundle. Click or tap the link on-screen
right now or in the description.